[Music]
it's easy to get caught up in the hype
of seeing our favorite Disney Princesses
interacting with each other in wreck-it
ralph - however we've noticed a few
disturbing things about our beloved
Merida that fans are less than happy
about we'll take you inside the
controversy and let you choose which
side you're on in the debate don't
forget to subscribe to the things if you
love Disney and hit that notification
belt and never miss another video now
let's check out what's going on with
Merida let's get this out of the way we
love Disney movies there's so much to
like about them and it seems like
they're getting better all the time
Disney has been around for so long that
it's not surprising they have some
regrettable things in their history
especially where women are involved for
a long time the company drew criticisms
because they constantly portrayed their
heroines as hapless and showed some
pretty disturbing relationship dynamics
you know like Belle's
Stockholm Syndrome or that it's okay to
kiss unconscious women on the off chance
they've been poisoned by a witch with
the passage of time and the raising of
voices it finally seen that Disney was
getting the message we wanted heroines
that were ready willing and able to save
themselves instead of relying on a man
to save them and going even further than
that what about a woman who doesn't have
or even want a man in her life in Disney
movies it seems like all women who fit
that description are always evil as if
having a relationship makes you a better
person and then we heard about the movie
brave directed by Mark Andrews and
Brenda Chapman Chapman drew inspiration
from her relationship with her own
daughter and became the first female to
direct a feature-length film for Pixar
things seemed to be looking good and the
movie itself was far from disappointing
the first thing we noticed about Merida
was her apparent and we were thrilled
that she looked so different than many
other heroines she has fiery thick and
unruly hair instead of the perfectly
poised locks of other princesses she
also looks like the teenage girl that
she's supposed to be and is a much more
realistic looking princess than we're
used to seeing instead of focusing on
finding a man Merida is already
betrothed to one and she isn't happy
about it we see her fighting her own
battles wielding powerful weapons and
basically being the princess we all
wanted to see when we were
little girls it seemed like Disney was
finally getting the message but then
things went south fans hoping to visit
the official brave website were in for
an unpleasant surprise when they
encountered a completely made over
Merida Disney took a character that we
adored because of how strong and well
brave she was and made her look like a
totally generic princess this new look
was supposed to come across as glamorous
but that's not an adjective we would
ever use to describe Merida it seemed
like Disney had taken two steps forward
and one step back with their handling of
Merida the new version looked thinner
older and much less like her normal self
people were deeply unhappy with the
change and were sure to let Disney know
they even started a petition on
change.org which gathered over 200,000
signatures even Brenda Chapman was
furious about the change and we don't
blame her one bit she even went as far
as calling it atrocious according to her
Merida was created to break the mold and
give young girls a good role model
thankfully it seemed like Disney finally
got the message again and removed the
glamorized version of Merida from the
website Disney released a statement
claiming that the design was intended to
be a one-off and had served its purpose
and would now be removed but of course
as we all know this story doesn't end
there one of the most exciting things
about the new wreck-it Ralph is the fact
that we're gonna get to see the
princesses on the big screen the good
news is that Merida is included with the
rest of the cast as she should be of
course but the bad news is that she
doesn't look anything like the original
version you may be willing to chalk this
up to the difference in animation styles
between brave and wreck-it Ralph - but
that just doesn't completely explain it
let's take a look at Belle Beauty and
the Beast came out decades ago and yet
she is completely recognizable after her
makeover same with Cinderella Aurora and
Snow White and their films came out way
before brave did at this point it's
pretty obvious that the cosmetic
differences between the Merida we met in
brave and the version we see in wreck-it
Ralph are intentional rather than accent
it looks as if Disney decided to go with
the glamorized version of merida that
they created instead of the original
version of merida that was such a
success with fans this just leaves us
wondering why who is this for
Merida was an important character who
arguably paved the way for stronger
Disney Princesses frozen is frequently
praised because Elsa and Anna didn't
rely on men to save them however both
heroines look much more like typical
Disney Princesses than Merida does and
you'll notice they look pretty much the
same in wreck-it Ralph too and when we
watch the trailer for the movie at first
it seemed like Disney was getting it
many of the other princesses seemed to
be making fun of typical Disney tropes
when trying to determine whether or not
vanellope is a princess the girls even
asked her if people always assume that a
man is gonna save her do people assume
all your problems got solved because a
big strong man showed up it seems like
Disney was trying to laugh at itself and
show that female characters can be
strong but if they truly believe that
then why did they use a glamorized
Merida instead of the original think
about it it can't be to impress Penelope
who wears a hoodie and looks very young
recognizing the problem is one thing but
to impress us Disney actually needs to
address it many fans are upset that
we're getting a dolled up version of
Merida and consider it to be an insult
towards an awesome character however
others think feeling outraged over
Merida's appearance is making a big deal
about nothing there's definitely no
denying that Merida looks different than
we're used to seeing her but is that a
good thing a bad thing or not really a
thing at all what do you think about the
Merida controversy are you still excited
to see all of the Disney Princesses in
wreck-it Ralph to tell us your thoughts
in the comment section and then click
subscribe for more videos from the
things bye for now
[Music]